the epicenter or coronavirus was one
from one the coronal virus has spreaded
all across the world till the end of
January the corona virus has spreaded to
Thailand Vietnam Singapore Australia
France and us in these regions and at
the end of February the situation is
detrimental because the spread is almost
global from India almost all part of the
Europe and Middle East USA South America
all of the places are now having cases
with corona virus and it is taking a
shape of a global pandemic and who has
announced it as a high risk situation
right now now the virus threat in India
is also high because almost 34 cases has
been detected in past few days and in
those most of the cases are in Delhi
Hyderabad Kerala Tamil Nadu chapul etc
so let us know in this video that how
coronal virus testing works and how we
can say that you are infected by the
corona virus and your taste is
confirmatory so what's this video till
the end
we know that corona virus mainly affect
your upper respiratory tract your lung
and cause pneumonia which is a key
factor or key symptom in corona virus
infection but how do you know that you
are infected or not let's say you have a
common cold versus you have Corona
how would you dealing it between these
two is there any confirmatory test that
you can do or in case you are having
symptoms like common cold what you can
do possibly let's see in order to
understand that we need to understand
the viral or she a little bit more
details so the corona virus enters our
lung epithelial cell by a particular
receptor called angiotensin converting
enzyme to receptor so it can enter by a
endo cytotec pathway so
stick up the virus with this interaction
with this receptor after it's in it
would affect the body but in this video
our main goal is to understand how to
detect the presence of corona virus the
corona virus having a genetic material
which is RNA in nature it's a plus
strand RNA apart from the genetic
material
there are envelope proteins there are s
proteins there are key proteins and M
brokens which are all accessory proteins
which are important for the viral
survival now what we need to know is the
viral genome encodes for all of these
protein so if the virus is there inside
your body you can at least detect the
RNA corresponding to these enzymes or
these proteins among the most important
proteins that the virus need for its
survival is included by rf1 and rf2
region which encodes for the replicates
which is important for the viral DNA
replication other than that the a
protein or the envelope protein is
important for the viral propagation and
survival because it interacts with the
entry receptor for the cell
other than that many other proteins such
as membrane proteins encoded by M region
or n region these are all important if
we are able to detect any one of these
fragment or a combination of these
fragments in a patient sample that means
possibly the patient is infected by the
virus because otherwise these things are
not supposed to be detected in a patient
sample
so let's see how we can detect corner
virus using real-time quantitative PCR
analysis real-time PCR analysis in short
is a technique by which you can
understand certain RNA or certain
transcripts are present in a sample or
not it can also tell how much it is
present and what is the relative
proportion of it now what is there but
we using real-time PCR which fragments
we are going to detect and there are
specific guidelines for that there are
many fragments which are ranging in or
f1 P or a portion of the e protein these
can be detected and several Institute's
are several research laboratories across
the world has used primers against
specific regions such as China used for
f1 B and for F n whereas Germany used a
different kind of PCR strategy but all
of these strategies are dedicated to
detect portion of the viral genome
present in the sample or not now every
country has their own way of doing it
but everybody is destined to detect the
presence of the viral genome now in
order to detect that generally the
healthcare officials takes your blood or
sputum sample then RNA is extracted from
that now the total RNA is converted to
complimentary DNA
imagine you have a viral RNA which is
present in your sample which is marked
here in yellow so the viral RNA would
also be converted to cDNA later on you
use specific primers to amplify portion
of these cDNA
now if the cDNA is not present then the
amplification would not take place and
that can be absolutely and quantified
kinetically detected by real-time PCR
real-time PCR out of real-time PCR is
very accurate and it works by a simple
principle it uses a cyber brain
chemistry fiber green dye based
chemistry a cyber green is a dye which
when does not bind to a DNA
has no fluorescence but when it binds to
DNA or a double-stranded DNA it
fluorescence
now as the PCR cycle moves on there are
many many cyber green molecules which
are binding to the new amplified DNA and
the signal amplifiers over time so if
you have too much of the viral RNA
quickly the signal would be amplified
and you would detect it like the
monitoring the change of fluorescent
levels and that is how you can
understand whether a person is infected
by the virus because at least you would
get the positive signal for this virus
infected person and the viral mRNA would
be detected in this real-time PCR assay
so you can detect a full change from a
control sample versus a patient sample
the e protein transcript level or the
RDP transcript level would be several
folds higher than a control person who
is non infect which is who is not
infected then that infected person and
that is how the health officials would
be confirmed that you are affected by
the corona virus or not but few things
we can do if we think that we are
affected or we came in contact with some
person who has a travel history from a
region of the world where corona virus
was spreading badly then we should not
go to a crowded environment we should
self quarantine ourselves because this
can not only the virus can not only
spread in form of droplets but it can
also spread in form of contact
contacting surface or handshakes these
things can allow this virus to spread
now the information that you should know
is the helpline number or corona virus
which is given here and also the
supportive email and if you think if you
think that you're infected you can
always drop them an email or ask them
for help and wearing proper mask and
isolation
improper bit
in hospitals are the only way to fight
coronavirus right now so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you